good morning heck it's Friday today I
share with you a story about guns indoor
tennis courts guillotines humorous
outfits and competing historical
narratives that's right it's time to
learn about the French Revolution okay
so quick background this is France
Frances in Europe French people like to
eat food and one other thing in the 18th
century there was this movement called
the Enlightenment wherein people
including French people like Jean
Jacques Rousseau and Voltaire were
starting to argue that rational thought
should be the source of truth and
authority instead of the interpreted
will of an omnipotent God that was a
slightly troubling thought to the French
monarchy which after all derived its
authority and therefore its ability to
purchase humorous outfits from the
supposed will of that affirm mentioned
omnipotent God okay so at 1789 the US
has just won its Revolutionary War which
by the way would have been impossible
without the support of France meanwhile
France has racked up tremendous debt
supporting the American Revolution and
also fighting the Seven Years War like
to give you a sense of Frances debt a
lot of people in the u.s. worried about
our national debt but in 2009 the United
States spent 5% of its federal budget
servicing its debt in 1789 France spent
50% of its federal budget servicing its
debt so France was completely broke but
the King of France Louie the 16th was
not broke as evidenced by his well-fed
physique
and fancy footwear Louie the 16th and
his wife Marie Antoinette had a pretty
comfortable life in the rather nice
Palace at Versailles which is the kind
of thing that will annoy you if you are
a peasant who is starving as I mentioned
earlier French people like a lot of
people enjoy eating so in 1789 in
addition to Frances debt crisis there
was a famine the price of bread rose 50
percent in one year but wages didn't go
up at all so the peasants are hungry the
intellectuals are beginning to question
whether power should be centred in the
church and the monarchy and the nobility
is dithering about failing to make
meaningful financial reform so in May of
1789 Louis the sixteenth recognizing the
crisis calls the convocation of the
estates-general a meeting of the three
estates of France the first estate is
the clergy the second estate the
nobility and the Third Estate everyone
else which is to say about 98% of the
population the Third Estate is paying
all the taxes producing all the wealth
fighting and all the wars meanwhile the
first estate the clergy pay absolutely
nothing in taxes I mean they have to be
celibate but still no taxes and then the
second estate the nobility's
most of each day playing an increasingly
high-stakes game of who can develop the
most humorous costume so the Third
Estate shows up with about 600
representatives the first and second
estates have about 300 representatives
each the Third Estate wants the
representatives from all three estates
to meet together in one assembly which
would basically become a governing
parliament in which the Third Estate
would have a very slight majority but
the first and second estate won't agree
to this so the Third Estate is like fine
you don't want to come to our party
forget you guys we the representatives
of the Third Estate are now the National
Assembly of France we are your
Parliament this does not please King
Louie 2:16 so when the Third Estate
people leave the room for a break Louie
the sixteenth locks the doors and says
sorry you can't go in there and if you
can't assemble you can't be in assembly
at which point the Third Estate
representatives were like hmm I think we
may have a solution to this problem the
Third Estate representatives
surprisingly are able to find a
different room in France an indoor
tennis court at Versailles and in that
room the new National Assembly swears
the famous Tennis Court Oath in which
they agreed that they will not stop
until they have written a French
Constitution at this point louis xvi
sees the writing on the wall he backs
down he says okay you guys can be a
national assembly but at the same time
louis xvi is flooding the city of paris
with troops who are loyal to him so
people actually start to think that
louis xvi might intend to destroy the
National Assembly by force at which
point the revolutionaries get a bright
idea
so on July 14 1789 the revolutionaries
stormed the Bastille prison not so much
because they wanted to free the seven
prisoners who remained there but because
they wanted guns and there were a lot of
them in the Bastille and this marked a
big turning point in the French
Revolution the governor of the Bastille
negotiated a ceasefire which saved a lot
of lives on both sides and that would
have been a great time for everyone to
say you know what if we start shooting
at each other this is probably gonna get
worse but instead they killed the
governor of the Bastille decapitated him
put his head on a pike and paraded it
around the next month the National
Assembly released the Declaration of the
Rights of Man and of the citizen the
French equivalent to the American
Declaration of Independence the
Declaration declared that all men sorry
ladies had the right to Liberty property
and security rights that the French
Revolution in the end would do an
exceptionally poor job of protecting me
back at versailles louis xvi was still
king of France and it was looking like
France might be a constitutional
monarchy which might have meant that the
royal family could hang on to their
awesome house but then in October of
1789 a rumor started that Marie
Antoinette was hoarding grain somewhere
inside the palace and in what became
known as the women's March a bunch of
armed peasant women stormed the palace
and demanded that Louie and Marie
Antoinette move from Versailles to Paris
which they did because everyone is
afraid of armed peasant women so between
May and October of 1789 France went from
a stable if somewhat broke monarchy to a
country where a bunch of armed peasant
women could functionally put the king
under house arrest a country where no
one quite knew who is running the show
and everyone had guns this problem will
soon get better and then worse and then
a little bit better and then much worse
and then better and then Napoleonic lis
were so stay tuned for that next time
Hank I look forward to you teaching me
something on Monday by the way with
permission from nerdfighteria we have
temporarily suspended the four-minute
rule just to get us through this week of
educational videos so those of you who
are commenting on how punished I am
clearly did not watch till the end of
the video which means that you missed
out on me proving that my suit isn't all
business